So we've learned that we can keep
our players coming back to our game
by creating some friendly competition.
But we also need to make
our game easy to return to.
Why don't you tell us
more about that yet?
>> Yeah,
say I've been playing Angry Birds for
a while on my phone and
I get all the way to level 30.
Then when I get home I switch
to my tablet to play and
I have to start all over at level one.
>> That's so frustrating.
I'd probably quit the game then.
>> Exactly.
And so would a lot of people.
So it's really important to have the
same progress across all your devices.
>> A simple solution to this
problem is to save your data
across all your devices in the Cloud.
So how would a game developer do that?
>> Well there are number of tools
out there that allow a developer to
link to the cloud.
For example, Amazon's dispersing for
game gives you the ability to sync your
game progress, scores, and
much more across all your cloud devices.
>> Let's learn more about this.